i I want to take this opportunity to do
a quick review of a research program up
being conducting a little bit a previous
at IBM and now in the Google one life
work that is around text input
it's a researching to review so it's a
clearly biased towards the work
published by these co-authors some I
actually want them at least what am I
sitting here Mitchell and many other
interns colleagues collaborators at
Google and L work so it's mostly
presenting joint work with them so
therefore it's not a comprehensive
literature literature review so I may
not have opportunity to give credit to
some other people who have done similar
work either prior or after our work so
also one Michael and James invited me
back to this seminar series for the
third time I I was hesitating a bit
hesitating a bit because being at Google
most of my time are spent on along with
colleagues to work on products that get
launched to buildings of users so it was
a lot of excitement as well as a lot of
attention needed to a lot of product
details at the same time I also enjoy to
do academic work so juggling between
both is quite a struggle so I was
hesitating whether I would be able to
find the time and that told Michael that
I I will if I would do it if I can cheat
a little bit that is I will do the same
work for two for the same assignment how
I was submitted to two places one
Stanford the other would be a keynote at
the upcoming IUI conference in in Cyprus
next week so because of that I want to
tie this line of work from ioi angle
and indeed I UI as a research community
it's a little bit of offshoot of Chi was
formed in the AI winter era and now the
ice in full swing again so I expect the
conference to be actually going to get a
lot more interesting as well so what is
I UI I look at the conference website it
basically says is where HCI meets AI
that's a pretty descriptive definition I
also looked up on Wikipedia it's a
little more informative the first
paragraph of Wikipedia IUI talks about
Microsoft Clippy which is not very
flattering way of defining the field the
second paragraph is actually quite
insightful it says it's basically a ioi
involves the computer side having
sophisticated knowledge of the domain
and or a model of the user and to me
that actually quite a good definition
that is you have either domain or users
behavior knowledge or ideally both and
to use that to help with user
interaction so why bother why are you i
well one word complexity so as we can
see experience you all have very
powerful computers that when I was doing
my PhD my advisor I had to buy a SGI
workstation that costed about a quarter
million dollar at a time to do my PhD
work now I actually just two years ago I
sent him a phone that if you look at the
Wikipedia specification it's greater
than the quarter million dollar
workstation inside I used on every
single dimension so but along with that
it also comes with a great amount of
functionalities and features even like
product managers your UI designers
engineers developers of the same product
do not necessarily know
the exist existence or operation of all
the features so there's a great deal of
complexity when it comes to user
interaction as well today something as
like for example you do know how many
settings there is on your phone and how
many different ways to configure your
phone it's it's actually rather rather
complex and that level of complexity is
actually increasingly harder to manage
with a traditional direct manipulation
100% direct mania the direct
manipulation approach something I said
long Dan is common is to say just a
volume control seemingly very simple but
when it comes to it it's what you're
you're controlling the volume for the
future or or what's happening now or is
the media is it ringtone is it the alarm
and so on and so forth and and sometimes
it can be quite critical this is about
eight or nine years ago I literally got
when I ended up in the hospital because
of just a volume control because I was
using iPhone at a time I had a some
dental work my dentist prescribed some
antibiotic just as a preventive measure
and he did warn me that if you have any
problem any symptom of antibiotic
complication call me and sure enough the
in afternoon I started to have diarrhea
and I was worried so I called him I said
but he wasn't in his office I left a
message I asked him to call me back and
I tuned the volume all the way down all
the way up so that I could hear and I
start continue to work and I never
received his call and then I realized I
had to go to the hospital and it was
that bad it turns out the volume where
all the way volume up doesn't mean the
volume is actually on at all so anyhow
there's just gritty of complexity to the
truth that he did call me except I
didn't hear it so I went to the pharmacy
first and eventually took
Magnusson eventually under in the
emergency room was actually pretty bad I
stayed in the hospital the first time in
my life for three days it wasn't it fun
it wasn't a fun experience so the point
is that just having a human come track
in human contraction is already complex
and often can be it's only going to get
more complex and sometimes very intense
one of the most intensive one of the
most intensive one of the most intensive
interaction experience is exactly text
input so text input is in general is
that difficult and a card into our
interaction experience you may not
realize that because we already spend
years and years of learning and
acquiring that scale and it's a human
endeavor in terms of coming up with
technologies to enable efficient text
input for centuries by now
and the background is the typewriter
that everybody once awhile wanted to
reform and change and reinvent here I
want to just show a fun video of
invention
[Music]
is buzzing over apple's latest must-have
gadget the MacBook wheel a revolutionary
new laptop that does away with the
keyboard tech trans reporter Jeff Tate
has more thanks Andrea
say goodbye to the keyboard and hello to
the future of laptop computers with the
MacBook wheel Apple has replaced the
traditional keyboard with a sleek touch
sensitive click wheel Apple CEO Steve
Jobs introduced the product yesterday at
the annual Mac Expo senior product
innovator Brian Gilman says the MacBook
wheel will make typing a thing of the
past at Apple our philosophy is create
products that are simple to use and
nothing's more simple than a single
giant button Gilman showed me how the
revolutionary new computer works just
open the intuitive alphabet menu here
scroll to the letter you need see and
Center click to select it then click
again to capitalize and repeat this
process for each new letter it couldn't
be simpler you can also let the
predictive sentence technology complete
the sentence for you Gilman says the
MacBook wheel has also simplified the
organization of files so searching your
hard drive will be a snap just press
both sides of the wheel concurrently and
center click in there you have an
alphabetical listing of every file on
your hard drive
everything is just a few hundred clicks
away Apple is calling the MacBook wheel
the most intuitive product ever designed
here at Apple we like to think that
we're giving customers features they
don't even realize they want yet while
the MacBook wheel won't hit the shelves
for another three to fifteen months many
Apple users already have it on their
wish list
I'll buy almost anything to China and
made by Apple Alex Alban was one of the
lucky few to get to try out a Mac wheel
and spent 45 minutes typing an email to
his friend I never really realized how
much I hated keyboards until I saw this
thing I liked having you know
matically says the MacBook wheel that
way people know you have one with a
price tag of just under $2,600 for the
lowest end MacBook wheel it is an
investment but the super thin laptop
features numerous innovations like the
new ultra-thin hummingbird battery which
can power the MacBook wheel for a full
19 minutes before needing to be
recharged and the computer how do I get
back to it okay so it's just it's fun
but it's not meant to be completely
comical because there's actually very
interesting points here about IUI about
how you can predict or should not
predict how you should also not predict
suggest information as a way of helping
the user the idea of like brings down
all the lists in the file system as well
as predicting every sentence you may you
may use and let you see user to choose
it's actually quite relevant to the
current talk so okay so so one of the
basic ideas of I you I of using machine
intelligence to help the user is to
predict and suggest to the user but
suggestions actually has cost so here is
a study we published last year this year
last year at chi in San Jose where we
actually studied a common technique that
is essentially used in all software
keyboard today actually prior to that
always using Chinese text input for many
decades before as well as the in AAC
accessibility community for people with
who needed alternative way of
communication the idea is that as you
give partial input the system predict
what you may need and give you multiple
choices or one initially the iOS design
give you one choice
and then everybody everybody pretty much
pretty much in the past few years
focused on three suggestions for verse
subtle reasons the question is that if
you make this suggestion and whether the
user should or will take it and why
there's actually cost associated with
suggestion that is there's a utility of
using that suggestion but there's also a
cost associated it cost being at least
the three aspects of it that is you have
to attend to the suggestion you have to
look at it and you have to evaluate
whether the suggestion is correct
or one of the correct ones is industry
among the suggestions and then if it is
right one you have to select it so if I
tap th and you suggest e then I have to
look at the e look at it knowing these
there and select the e then what's the
point
I may as well just type letter E so all
this cost combined may outweigh the
benefit and that's a simple way of
looking at it and this pioneered by sue
card and others in terms of modeling
elemental steps of interaction that will
give you some sense about the
interaction design efficiency or design
a goodness but turns out it's also a lot
more complex than that so this paper was
actually done in maybe around year 2012
ish we actually did a lot of modeling
work for this paper that was a primary
purpose of this paper but then I
rejected it it
everybody has rejected papers even James
does so and then we resubmit it as a
short note that's only giving the
empirical results with other modeling
part but what what you can see is that
it's actually far more complex than
designers think if you only think about
the benefit of this suggestion so you
can present
suggestions the system can always has
best case always has best case always
says best predictions but it also should
have an internal confidence estimate so
you can make the system
extraverted in a sense that the system
will always say something regardless its
company or not or it can be integrated
it will never say anything even though
it knows you really want this word could
save you a lot of time if you take this
word or and be worded that is skated by
some sort of a utility calculation
internally so we try these experiments
constructed the experiment so that
people can take a different you eyes and
we come to realize users don't always
take them you can see that the black bar
is the amount of time or taps that could
have been saved or offered but what
people actually take was much less than
that so people do don't take every
suggestion even if it's correct so their
savings a lot less than the theoretical
estimate and also when they take it you
can see the one they do ticket so on
this side extraverted taken making more
suggestions people also take more when
people take more their average speed
it's actually lower than the actually
introverted that's there's no suggesting
you just type every single letter my
Canas please this would sort of be four
into that like it so it breaks my typing
flow to access suggestion and I'm
wondering you know two of that like
conceptually it seems like you could do
up to what is that a 17% improvement or
something like that I'm wondering is
this sort of averaged over every key
press like because some of the the winds
might have to fight depend on how really
you can do the prediction yes so so that
the utility that is if I type
acknowledgement yes a long word I type a
C and I take that suggestion that
utility is much higher so that's the
this that's the modeling part that we
factored in so
we look at the that type of calculation
as well yes but but it's also far more
complex than that is people do like it
and also people use it not necessarily
for keystroke savings but more for we're
not sure about the spelling I use
suggestion all the time when I type
Chinese because my opinion so lousy I
just have to look and try my chance or
people try to use that to verify all
that indeed is a correct spelling before
they commit to it
so there's other choices but still this
topic of suggestion the cost was person
or completion for that matter is it's
pretty deep and it's a very central
challenge to I for example you know we
now have Google home we have Siri we
have all kinds of assistant that's all
based on some sort of prediction based
on a little bit information you gave it
I need just believe that it will give
you an sometimes Google over say I don't
know that yet but these are all still
ongoing research challenges we I don't
think we get a very good hang of it
study where I have to take a sentence
and transcribe it like spelling is to be
less of an issue that can see it right
there whereas the case you just say
think of it I might need that help
your study my under yeah I I'm sometimes
just look at the most aggressive use of
this today and it's also very clever use
of today is in Google Gmail auto reply
so you don't need to give any input it
guesses you wanted this short sentence
James that's great so what sometimes
that's what I want to say and and the
valleys in cost is not that high the the
attending or the motor selection cost is
not very high either but the potential
gain is very high so I don't have type
type type i anything but the
it's fairly introverted that is it
doesn't say that all the time you only
say that when you when they believe that
has high chance to hate to hurt you
right and you have your own judgment
people have their judgment wire this is
going the design is quite conservative
it it only predict predicts most common
and I'll touch on a personalization a
little bit later so let me go back to
support but suggest it's not the only
way to use machine intelligence the
other way to use instant moving
intelligence is to to correct because
humans can are generally not meant to be
very precise very mechanical at doing
things so you can use the same kind of
machine intelligence to correct or
complete users incomplete or partial or
erroneous or sloppy input that would be
another way to help the user and there's
always a speed accuracy trade-off if you
allow the user to be more sloppy and
then it can be also faster so how do we
do that in the context of keep modern
keyboard this is what I call the
standard model and it's quite
straightforward so basically the by
definition what we want is that user has
some sort of input and this input is
expressed as a signal that signal can be
a set of touch points or a sloppy
gesture or a combination voice of
something that can be can be anything
that it's a signal and this signal has
to be understood by the system by the
system an assist him look at a signal
given the signal will look for all in
theory all possible words of course in
practice has to do clever pruning and
and traversing to find the right word
quickly to give you the word it thinks
you want and that's the basic problem by
definition so this is what it does but
how to do that of course there's not a
simple lookup table
you can look for every single signal
give every word
what you need is word I you I come
seeing that is first of all you need a
knowledge about the user or the new user
behavior specifically specifically that
is for any given world how likely the
user is expressing it with the
particular signal you receive the signal
s every given word what what's the
probability of user do it that way
rather than some other way and what's
the probability of that so that's what
what we call a spatial or motor model or
user model in general user behavior
model and then with this knowledge you
can that's it's almost a completely
reverse of the decoding of the problem
itself it's a given signal we won't find
a word now you have a mod of given word
you know based on your knowledge of the
user you can infer what's that word at
what probability and then thanks to the
famous space rule you can flip side and
multiply that with the prior probability
which of that word which is inferred
from context and that is commonly known
as the language model or you can also
say that's the domain knowledge that's
embedding you know I UI for text input
so that's the general framework every
system I'd argue works this way one way
or another maybe they're not aware of it
maybe it's indirect but it's one way or
another this is how a modern keyboard
works now the question is that where do
we get these knowledge or user models
and what are they so James you had a
question I really welcome welcome
questions because this has a lot of
different things and I giving me
questions will give me clue about how to
steer it but I do want to get to the end
of it let's say so what's the user model
of when it comes to touchscreen
interaction the first thing comes to our
mind is the famous f-word in HCI namely
if it's law so but interestingly this
foundation piece too
cooee into her instructing design it
actually doesn't apply to to touchscreen
at least doesn't apply to touchscreen
strictly so Paul Feig's himself did
experiments with stylus this transfer
packing hall kind of three types of
tasks in the 1950s sooo card brought
this to the airfield or even before I
see I've filled was formally formed in
1978 to study the mouse cursor behavior
as well as George steaks and other
cursor control behaviors but basically
it's based on single point so the
absolute control position is in the
problem the problem is the relative
position that is how relative the error
the target is tolerant to errors in
comparison to the amount of movement you
have to make so we had to do a
remodeling of a fits law to provide a
fixed forefinger touch this is exactly
what we did a few years ago called a
finger face fall so basically from the
traditional Fitz law we'll have to
subtract certain amount of absolute
amount of error due to finger
imprecision commonly known as the Fed
finger so this is really a formal
solution to the fact finger problem but
still has a problem in when it comes to
keyboard because it only applies feel
only applies to one movement tribal
movement one point of movement or one
point of travel but in reality people
some people type with one finger but
other people do to thumb or one thumb
and and still others would do all
combination of three depending on the
situation so that makes it very
difficult to apply a simple Fritz law or
even think a finger is law to model it
so what it comes down to essentially
it's not a complete model is that we
know the distribution of the model if
you for the touch point if you look at
the touch points basically it's a
Gaussian distribution look at them all
together collectively on this side use
one finger the spread is slot the the
Gaussian distribution spread
inside and outside of target key it's
little less than thumb thumb would
spread even wider with two thumbs
slightly wider but you can view
everything as a Gaussian and once we
have that Gaussian distribution as a
user behavior model then factor that
into the general equation I listed
earlier you can solve this quite easily
into a very simple operation essentially
the decoding the decoder does is that
measuring the touchpoints distance in
case of touch to the center of each key
and that combined with a language model
by Cinco simply a lognormal combination
addition you will get the probability
cost of every single world in it in a
database in the language model so and
that can be solved easily very elegantly
and and and comes to a very simple
companies you know operation as well yes
are people at all optimal in this in the
sense that like do we tend to pick
fingers that do a good job or are we
actually blind to what actually works or
is it or is the actual effect of it so
minimal that most people wouldn't notice
the difference and so they don't adjust
their grip to type effectively like how
much of joint learning is happening here
example is that I feel sometimes people
will find the best way for the situation
like an when you're walking and you're
also talking or holding coffee you use
one thumb you're half the time you focus
you use two thumbs and sometimes you use
one finger it changes but another hand I
did not know a good way of doing typing
is actually holding with one four
gestures I think is holding with one
more or less with one hand but the other
hand is doing with the thumb that turned
to be a more stable control loop than
than this your friend Tom young told me
about it and I really like yeah
afterward after awhile I did find that
it's most preferable but I be prior to
that I didn't know that was as a you
newse I didn't know that was actually
preferable so we still I don't have a
complete answer on that yes nowadays
aren't a lot of us sliding rather than
pressing keys yeah
so now but what's interesting is that
these different watertight wallet what
we call Hank postures will give you a
very different distributions so on this
side you can see use a single finger you
tend to type lower than the key Center
by a larger amount then if you type with
a thumb and so on so forth
laterally you can also see some keys
turn to be typed more biased towards the
center and others more biased outwards I
think there's this word typed about
words so it really depends on both the
hand posture which key or which location
of the key because organ organ amelie
always obvious they're different when
you try to bend your finger or trying to
extend your finger those are all cost
different biases so if we know these
biases then we can factor a more precise
prediction about how you would express
each letter and therefore we can have a
better model better spatial model or
user model and then you will give better
prediction therefore better correction
as well so that's precisely what we try
to do that is we build models for each
finger posture as well as individual as
well as you imagine is personalized
it's a to the user to the key position
to hand posture and all three factors
then you will do the best possible job
in terms of decoding for the user but
however that means you have to know they
are in that mode how do you know if you
have a very sophisticated user and users
hand to know but that's quite difficult
to do practically so we have to infer
from behavior data backwards to know to
do a classification such as a SVM to
find out whether they're doing
typing with one finger out typing with
smooth arms or a one thumb even so okay
so i've seen a character error rate
going down by about a full percent which
could translate into tens or hundreds of
fewer errors in a day I'm wondering if
we blinded people to which condition
which model they were in do you think
that they could actually figure out
which one looks better or not like is
this is this a difference that people
can perceive is it something that maybe
they would get sort of a a sense
intuitively that maybe it's just a
little smoother but they would never can
point it on the model like I'm curious
how much of this actually purpley it's
up you know into the perceptual layer
and a cognitive layer and how much of it
is is left you know again another good
question wait I don't I I I don't think
we have a good answer on that on one
hand again you feel very just let's say
a percentage of change 1% wer reduction
in speech recognition would be a huge
breakthrough that people don't believe
you generally you can achieve that much
but so usually they talk talk about
relative to wer so then if you see you
begin with 10% you reduce 1% it's it's
10% of what's remaining that's how you
the generally reported to to make it
sound a bit more but also maybe that's
what matters but what what's interesting
is that so
to the end user experience is that what
that 1% how much that translates to
their overall user experience it really
depends it's it's a it's hard I'm most
imagining a 2 by 2 study where and like
you're you're manipulating the model but
also manipulating say like that mediocre
to a deep to a good interface and I
wonder if people would attribute the
difference a to a better interface and
in fact what you're doing is changing in
a model like it it's sort of like it's
just smoother I don't know how but it
actually it just feels better somehow
those look great three six questions Oh
touch the download again again play
doctor
Wow okay I'm joined increasing student
just that that so okay but the next
story here those character level
reductions those are at character level
ICU tech each character before a foodie
coatings apply to when you apply a food
decoding on it that leverages lot more
power from length model these are pretty
much washed out so at this level but
again this level is also assuming
detection ability in and so and so forth
so it's it's an interesting idea
so we idealize the back off that is when
the system doesn't know what what your
what the how what specific posture the
usually stood or which individual that
was you apply a general base model as
you have system gain confidence to infer
the mode or state or or particular state
in this state transition paragraph a
graph and it will apply a more specific
model the last thing you want is that it
applies the finger model to the thumb
and then catch you even worse results
that's you don't want so but but
nonetheless all things considered this
still very very at this moment not
worthwhile to do so we're still
basically applying a general model a
base model so the other way to use IUI
is to just reduce the amount of work
user has to do so earlier we talked
about ambiguity in touch in touch but
actually gesture or sliding keyboard
from one letter to another by definition
will give you a lot more ambiguity often
there are many many letters along the
way that's not what you need it for that
word so i'm i've talked about this
before actually in the last PCD i gave
about seven year years ago from a
different angle that is how it how we
consider this learning problem and how
do we facilitate learning and how do you
facilitate the transition from initial
video guided behavior to on
on recall based behavior I'll just do a
short video to refresh that follow shark
is a pen based text input system it
combines a stylus keyboard with pen
gesture recognition technology the
keyboard layout can be either the
standard QWERTY or the atomic layout
shown here that is optimized for stylus
motion for each word in our large
lexicon a shorthand symbol for our sock
breath is defined by connecting the
words letters on the keyboard for
example the word word is represented by
the letter trace w o VAR d the newest
user can look at a keyboard and trace
the letters of the intended word here
the user is writing the phrase the quick
brown fox jumps over the lazy dog
unlike speech recognition error
correction is relatively easy with the
pen based shark method if a mistake is
made the user can select a correct
choice from the invest list embedded in
a text stream editor or delete an
unwanted word from it a new user can
also use the animation feedback feature
for luring soft grabs the animation
morphs the user's pen gesture to the
ideal soft graph of the word the system
recognizes
over time the user may remember the
shapes of those well-practiced words and
a shift from video tracing to recall
based pattern gesturing as a result the
input speed may increase dramatically we
use a multi-channel pattern
classification system to recognize the
gestures draw on the keyboard in
particular a shape channel looks at so
this was really by internet or or mobile
age is really engine history now mr.
Tong started in 1999 first the video I'm
showing is 2004 that was made during our
summation to waste 2004 that we were
given what was called lasting impact
award just a couple years ago so but at
the time the press really loved it even
call it new way of writing Mercury News
and why listen it's indicated by to some
hundred newspapers around world but most
people were quite skeptical that whether
there's something here that's that's
actually really worth a business
attention so today it is in most in both
iOS Android platforms and it's freely
available under many many brands made by
many engineers and different companies I
won't show the video but I what I want
to talk about so how do we evaluate the
text input systems this come up a few
times at lunch as well as during this
talk so far text input evaluation is
really really difficult because there
are so many aspects of it
for example there's always a speed
accuracy trade-off
so if you do it make a lot of mistakes
and you can type over fast and that
doesn't mean it's necessarily better
than a slower one but with no no error
but yet when you get results that
changes in both dimensions there's no
model that tells us how many errors
worth how many words traditional typing
contest every keystroke error would
count as five words or something that so
but that's a kind of arbitrary so how do
we deal with that the research field
generally don't seem to want to
recognize evaluations it's very complex
evaluation always answer some questions
and raise many more others but that just
like a this is by now about 20 years ago
James probably know that provocative I
say I wrote in response to Henry
Lieberman he argued about evaluations
the is the enemy of research and I I
said that evaluation is the only way of
doing research except over others
paraphrasing Churchill in terms of
democracy but now we also know the most
it doesn't always work either but still
it still is the best so interesting port
how do we do this evaluation
there's also difficulty in terms of
human learning so any given method you
takes a lot of time to master so this
leads to difficulties in terms of like
traditionally the debates between diva
rock and QWERTY keyboard to date it was
not a resolved question a topic also
once the keyboard is smart in the sense
that it has a language model then there
will the issue of a language coverage
for example if you have a smart keyboard
oh what it does is one word like wrd and
whatever you doing we'll give you the
word word then for that word definitely
can do much faster than any other
implemented but but it doesn't have any
coverage so if you have one heart won't
have coverage or traditional way of
studying text input like having a few
people typing some method for an hour
- or even for a week isn't just going to
be enough to cover the language
phenomenon McConnell she's logging to do
to measure results the logging has its
own problem other than privacy logging
also doesn't give you the users
intention so you don't know when whether
they actually made a mistake or not and
you have to guess that and also there's
a real world versus lab context so here
is the example we took this method by my
former student parola who at the time
was at this in andrews university now is
that Cambridge and his student
shyam at San Jose we did the study that
inspired by a common research method he
knew you become field that is you excute
embed test in everyday life you can call
it experience sampling here is more
performance sampling so we prompt the
user randomly throughout the day ten
times a day either they are walking or
eating or something and ask them to do a
short sentence and the results actually
very different from life studies that's
one thing but still the study results is
quite complex here we can see generally
there's some advantage to gesture typing
or or slide or swipe or word gestures
that then tap-tap-tap kind of a style
typing generally speaking but it's not
completely unequivocal the most
unequivocal and comprehensive answer
here is kind of voting by by by hand in
the sense that so we allow the user to
actually also use the method outside of
the study so we also ask them how often
before and after how often to the use
gesture typing versus tap typing and you
can see for participant 5 & 6 & 7 & 8 &
10 & 11 they or one they had no use of
gesture typing before I stick a stand
for smart gesture keyboards no use of it
were not either not aware of it or or
didn't use it but this study self in the
process because learned this skill and
some
everybody become much more use than
before I some become 100% convert like 9
or 3 afterwards
they use 100% of time our chests ready
and people started with gesture I think
before the study I still end up just
reading after study that is those two so
that's a clear more comprehensive
evidence that people do like overall
better but how do we parse that to
individual aspects of the performance is
still rather complex so back to the same
of IUI that is how much you want to help
the user how much you take that work to
the you to the to the system to do is
has many ramifications one of them is
that the gestures define encore he is
actually pretty poor it's all the exact
very similar can we turn it around
indeed you can see from the video the
the keyboard used was called atomic the
idea was that the keyboard was optimized
to minimize movement as a side effect it
actually is also pretty good for gesture
typing this is the word writing on the
keyboard of atomic and then more
recently we asked ourselves this was
with it's not internet Google can we
actually optimize for clarity that is
statistically the gestures defined on
keyboard would have less chance to
collide with each other so for example
on corty the word Oh our and the word
old you are completed collide and this
is just example their many words
actually are very very similar but if we
allow to move the words around letters
around then the shapes defined by this
keyboard would begin to change and then
you can still using optimization
techniques to push all words basically
apart rather than push them together and
that's what we call clarity but clarity
is not that easy to do but but still
much easier to do then you think about
that's not only thing the only thing
that matters another dimension that
matters the speed that is if you push
all the letters into the outside the
gestures will be more far apart but
every word you do a very large gesture
so I have to concede as well and most
important you have to consider how easy
it is to learn that key layout so in
here we factoring the keyboards
similarity to corty as another dimension
so if you look at just two of them
little easier to look to see this is
gesture typing accuracy clarium this
dimension and typing speed another
dimension you can see this theoretical
prediction that Corday's right in the
middle and you can achieve better on
each dimension and both dimensions so
the best a some are here
that's better than key quarry by a large
margin in both dimensions but still is
still ongoing research because when it
comes to learning people have a great
amount of bias in terms of investing
time for the future versus my time today
is the most valuable bye-bye by a huge
margin so still ongoing work now let me
switch to the domain knowledge in text
input that is not language modeling so
language modeling traditional is quite
simple it's just you can think viewed as
a list of words with with set
probabilities and great known as an
Engram probability like thank followed
by you is thank him is uh well less
likely but so you have there you have
you you have a list of words that
follows preceding words knowing grant
models more recently there's more neural
net based representation of language
models which can be more compact or more
efficient or more information but the
concept is quite simple the actual
production of language model is very
very complex because it really has to do
with outcome has
with the quality of the training corpora
your supply to the trainer
there's also filtering problems that is
if you just get a tech amount of a huge
amount of text from the web you'll find
all kinds of inappropriate insensitive
or simply plain wrong language models so
you have to do proper filtering and then
there's policy issues like user will get
mad at you if would give you a profanity
word by mistake but but user will be
other user would be very very outraged
at that what your keyboard doesn't me to
use the f-word come on
so also the development of course
training dev test set to be separate and
so on so forth so anyhow a particularly
interesting topic for the text input
area which I mentioned briefly earlier
is personalization so if you assume if
you assume people talk somewhat
differently then you want to adapt to
that particular users a style and how
much gain that would give you so this is
a paper we published a few years ago
that makers when you don't use language
model the keyboard comes down keyboard
and you make about 40% of errors in fact
quite quite large but as long as you
apply a backward or you can reduce that
too in this simile this is a simulation
study to around 6% and then if you apply
a person line like personalized language
model you get another 1% absolute
reduction or 20% about 20% relative
reduction typing tasks because if you're
trying to personalize like I may
actually be typing different things
again whatever some generic tasks set
yeah yeah and it's a thermos bomb going
research but they also imply how do you
study back you have you study a locus
model of the best of you sir
actually has a long-term benefit so how
much you can afford a long-term
observation so this is actually quite
creating the study is that we took the
goldmine of NLP that didn't have a
privacy barrier that is namely the I run
email corpus and that has many years of
history Oh track to individuals so you
can know if I have this model for this
person but guys are for example and four
years later how that I word will do to
his typing and actually typing so we
have a user model Amelie I started
typing particular way to style in
particular bias with with with error and
then you can simulate this process with
a new language model versus a baby
comparison and you find out what this is
how we got the results but then yours
also observe these things like you adapt
it maybe improvement but of a sudden and
I'm gonna get to see what everybody's
talking about different things and then
the model would may not behave as wise
used to one and then it needs that
tissue in it so and so forth so it's
very much ongoing research that is still
not conclusive but generally there's
some game to be made personalization
okay so I think I'll skip this one
I'll talk last topic that Mitchell did
at Google that also concerns the theme
of this particular talk that is how much
I oh I can help easier interaction so
text input on phone was difficult enough
I'm gonna watch a smaller steel computer
the fat finger gets really fat relative
to the thumb today watch it's about
one-third or one-half of the watch so
how do you do that how do you do a
keyboard on our watch the traditional
HCI method some very clever from the our
own field but obviously more
conventional field I
idea is that well since the finger is
too fat what do you do you make the
keyboard virtually more error tolerance
by breaking them each key to two steps
like you tap once the keyboard zooms up
and you type second time this time your
fingers not as fat as last time
therefore you get it right or you move
shifts the keyboard you only display
half the keyboard at one time and so on
so forth
you can think of many many methods to do
this but the general idea is that you
break down the task into more steps and
more element it's a reasonable idea but
it means the user has to do more work
rather than less so we first thought
about this even myself thought yeah it's
kind of crazy but let's say human will
take some hit by trying to be a little
more precise but let the ambiguity or
the errors to be handled by intelligence
by the Machine maybe maybe the Machine
can resolve it so I'm sure enough this
is what me to date not only real so can
we present watch writer a finger
operated keyboard that supports both
touch and gesture typing with
statistical decoding on a smart watch
just like on modern smartphones users
take one letter per tap or one word
progesterone on watch writer but in a
much smaller spatial scale watch waiter
demonstrates the combination of human
motor control adaptability with modern
statistical decoding and error
correction technologies developed for
smartphones could enable a surprisingly
effective typing experience despite the
small watch size so you can see the
result on the lower right corner the
either tap or gesture on watch by using
physical decoding went by afraid a large
margin is usually not that obvious but
in this case is very obvious than
conventional purely manual approach
typical wpm today I would say around
between average 30 to 40 words per
minute as the average this study tend to
vary quite a bit but that's my best
guess based on all kinds of evidence for
example wealthy
earlier you have that so this is the
study on the top wpm yeah 38:30 some
this is what again one study that's
another difficult question that is what
is what's the typing speed on keyboard
on regular key 40 keyboard traditionally
secretaries can only be qualified as a
secretary if the type 60 words per
minute but my sense is that varies
widely
most people type much faster today yes
variation so in terms of what are
aspects of people that cause that
variation I could guess like a list say
like working memory capacity
maybe conscientiousness or motivation if
they're trying really hard
you mentioned motor control for the
Smart Watch I would imagine like
proprioception like mmm like knowing the
space between fingers what else is
determining the learning curve between I
don't know and I I think like this is
actually how I started this line work at
first I got into virtual keyboard
studies when I was like my friend Scott
McKenzie was doing some studies
presenting the Chi and they were doing
keyboard optimization say well you're a
wrench keys and you can at the time was
stylus typing you tap with when stylus
it turns out actually other people mean
a you see if you have done this much
earlier and much more aggressively for a
while but I was sitting in it listening
to the talk I said well so it's only 26
letters so what people are learning why
it's too difficult to learn can we make
the keys somewhat different can we just
make some keys stand out can we add more
visual features would that make the
learn faster or faster and so and so
forth I did this
not cover today would publish number of
papers I had one intern from Stanford
SEC Department Paulie and worked on this
quite a while frankly the more we study
this the more we come to conclusions we
just have no clue we just have no clue
how people learn
we just don't one factor time on target
the more time you spend on it the more
you learn other than that I actually
talked with the Santa Cruz psychologist
of her famous one and he said oh yeah we
know that he does the skill acquisition
kind of studies and we all know that if
you get a doctor from 200 years ago to
ask a doctor to treat you out today's
problem the doctor has no clue what to
do today you get a teacher from 200
years ago a good teacher today that
teacher would be still a good teacher
that just means home so much about
learning it's a practice not a theory
that's kind of interesting
anyhow so yeah that's still a great deal
of interest to to me and many other
researchers so the work on more work in
that area in terms of learning actually
literally we are that's the next
breakthrough I think the paradigm
gesture typing can truly get to the
notion of shape writing for a while kind
of shape writing that is you really
remember shapes but that means we'll
have to change the keyboard layout that
means we'll have to find a way for
people to learn I have learned one
layout like atomic and other users still
going after me today saying well why
don't you bring atomic back but I just
felt it's just too hard to learn how are
we how we can find a good learning that
maybe just like a simple game I don't
know let's say what C let me close by
saying that the the rapid breakthrough
seen in machine learning is also
bringing more and more opportunity to
HCI but also brings a lot of challenges
as we get better the user perception or
experience often gets either worse or
the users potential raises so there's
all forms of ankeny uncanny valley
HCI that we I think I weigh as a field
should should invest more and do more
research on and the other challenge is
that most success is seeing in machine
learning comes from a natural phenomena
like large amount of images large amount
of speech data that can be labeled
usually in case fish actually done by
human transcription or even machine
translation also has already existing
translated text as labeled data large
data set to help the machine learning
algorithms to find the best
representation but in HCI behavior wise
user behavior is interactive it's not
this is what you do therefore that's the
right thing that's wrong thing or every
gesture is a word these are that gesture
is somewhat defined by your design so
it's also usable changes like in gesture
typing people start with going from one
letter to another but over time they
will become more fluent and then will
cut corners also knowing the system can
take that tolerance they become more and
more the what we call minimum Turk Turk
minimization a model I escaped today my
former intern now he's a colleague will
probably have a chance to talk about
that but but the difficulty is that
there's not an easy way to label data
therefore there's not easy way to train
a neural network to do interaction
algorithms easily evaluation continue to
be a challenge so I'll stop there are
already over run a little bit but thank
you very much for your attention and
asked more questions
I was really good very good thank you
[Applause]
so let's relate to the early question of
teaching so the idea is that you draw or
gesture and the gesture animates to the
idea that tells you the amount of
tolerance it has and also tells you what
the ideal gesture is or when kids make a
mistake enemies to a different word and
you understand oh that's the word I
really was more closer to than than the
word intended and it's a fun feature but
generally wasn't magical the reasons
that users attention is always ahead of
the task so when they type one word
gesturing one word there their attention
is on the next word or next is next
starting point so they don't usually pay
attention to to that so there's actually
keyboards a little harder to say but
other predictive methods like let's say
we want to predict instead you go look
for whining 1,000 apps you may use for
this moment why doesn't the actress
launch itself or at least presents
itself say well here's the happy one and
we have this both on iPhone and allies
today I always enjoyed today but that
prediction can be like simple eyes
something just recently what what are
the reason used apps and what's
displayed in one place and you look for
it and that cost use expression class is
much lower than say it also consider
location time of day or some other magic
signals and use large amount of signals
and present somewhat better but less
reasonable reasonable in the sense that
you think you can expect it's hard to
expect what's going to be presented and
that in a way you have greater cost as
you get closer to perfection
they're not that's one form of uncanny
valley there are many other forms I find
I just think it come up Oh quite quite
often not nicely in the original sense
of like when you have something a robot
that really looks like a really like a
human it's actually more more uncanny
but putting a broader in the broader
sense and we certainly see these
products like assistants kind of type of
products if it's just no I do search and
I know what I was looking forward to
give me results and I know that's a not
the right one but I totally understand
it I sort of more forgiving but you know
conversant knowing the race it gives me
back something that is that's not
appropriate or ridiculous and the user
gets less that's forgive me yes so with
more opportunities for more spatial
gestures and mediums like VR have you
thought about how you can transfer your
work here to completely new spaces for
you know
areas where text input isn't really you
know you need upon actually papers on
that already what particular form you
said you gesture you make the shape
writing gestures in air with with some
sort of a finger tracker that's you know
people have done that usually not very
good surprising the surface has a lot of
very good interaction properties in the
sense that the moment you touch the
surface your finger knows you touch the
surface the surface knows you touched it
so there's no ambiguity in terms of
segmentation if you do chest you're
seeing in air where's the beginning
where's the end if you use a clutch it
gets awkward and hold that but again
maybe we'll have better intelligence
will have better user model better
domain knowledgeable people to do high
no more ambiguity that's still very much
open question yeah
hey most frustrating when I'm trying to
type word and like more than once it
will tell me to suggest the wrong word
or converted into the wrong studies done
as using as if there will be amount to
which a user correction or a choice of
thing the algorithms first choice the
amount of which that changes the program
behavior and whether that has two
answers one is that yes actually want
the basic basic logging based metric is
the amount of time the percentage of
time you take the suggestion so when the
word is come out of algorithm especially
when it comes out in case of tapping
it's different from the literal string
your tabbed and give you a the
percentage was taken by the user without
overriding it is the basic indication of
how well we're doing with our algorithm
so that's the one answer more general
answer but the flip side and the other
answer is that often these are just
viewed as bugs there are indeed bugs
bugs in the sense that it you actually
had a word that should have been in your
language model at least a personalized
language model but it isn't so that's
just we view it as a bug it just
wouldn't happen so either our production
system didn't consider the use case like
your contact or a friend's name in
facebook should have been in there we
didn't have the pipeline to actually
feed it into it so therefore didn't it
know that name
and you thought like we we have this
kind of you know internal feedback and
people got outraged how come my son's
name is not in the dictionary it's just
ridiculous yeah so that happens yeah
it's that's just a bug in a way but it
does again reflects the coverage and
domain matching of a language model with
with the actual use
all right now if that reminded that we
should never take our phones prototyping
for granted and I thank our Sweigart one
last time
thank you
[Applause]
you